[Music]
[Music]
good
[Music]
so
[Music]
this
[Music]
hey what's up everyone matthew and cena
here stepping in for mr christo it's
been a while
since i've been on the live stream so
it's really nice to see all of you
here and i'll be on these live streams
hopefully a little bit more frequently
i've just been trying to get my act
together because i've been so busy
working on other stuff so it's nice to
see you let us know where you're tuning
in by dropping it in the chat um
yeah because it's been a while so if
things fall apart here and get
a little uh a little messed up it's
because i'm pretty rusty running these
live streams and hopefully
jonah will help me out but today what
we're going to be talking about is
how to improve your design by exploring
many mediums and different industries
and we have a special guest today which
we'll introduce in a second but
we'll look at some of his work talk
about his career then we're going to do
a little bit of an
overview and tutorial on some of his
work how to create some beautiful
3d typography going through his process
oh we got some people from kuwait
nigeria philippines
yeah it's nice to see all of you from
belgium and dubai
all over the place all over the place
and i i love seeing the the diversity
here and i know some people are up
super late we're up super early just to
join us so thank you for joining us so
now i'd actually like to hand it over to
our guest to introduce himself
and so we could look at some of his work
and figure out who he is
yeah who's saying welcome to the show
good to be here thank you for having me
very excited to
join you and join the whole team it's a
pleasure yeah so for those
of uh our audience who don't know you
yet who are you and uh what do you do
so if you don't know yet my name is
and i'm a product designer and cgi
vfx artist i run my own studio
and musawi studios and i'll walk you
through
some of my beginnings how i started and
how i got to where i am today
so so yeah if you guys want to start
yeah let's go
let's take a look at some of your work
so yeah and as you guys are looking at
this stuff if you have questions
don't forget to drop it in the chat
jonah will surface it for us if there's
anything that comes along but we will
have
an opportunity at the very end to um
dedicate to q a cool
cool cool so so yeah my beginnings uh
where it all started for me
uh i always had this passion for design
passion for art
and i came from a very small island in
the middle of
the other side of the world compared to
the us and it's called bahrain
and i always thought of myself as a
dream chaser i had these big dreams
i wanted to work for companies like nike
adidas these big brands that we have and
enjoy buying their products and that's
where the passion really grew for me so
uh just being in high school i used to i
used to design stuff for fun
and trying to find my passion and what
i'm really excited about
and it started by doing stuff like this
which was
desktop wallpapers which was pretty
popular in the end of the 90s beginning
2000s
and this was all for free you know like
just do it for fun
do it for the joy and we had like a
design crew people from all around the
world
just designing wallpapers get to know
each other and and then we had different
crews
like we're competing against other crews
and yeah no money involved
all the pictures i think we we took lots
of pictures which were all copyrighted
yeah no i think we all started that way
let us know
in the chat if you started here because
i remember some of my first photoshop
work that i did were collages like this
for
like final fantasy backdrops and stuff
like that
so i think a lot of us started here
exactly exactly and it's just a passion
for i had a passion for two things
honestly that led me to my
uh to my journey and that was design and
sports
so i loved basketball i loved soccer and
i always just did this stuff for fun
when i was in school middle school high
school
and it's crazy to see like you have
tracy mcgrady and
i was able to work on a project for him
with adidas
you have lebron james i was able to do
something for him through nike
so it's just crazy to see like where i
started and where that passion took me
and i'll talk
a bit more about that journey through
this presentation
uh so yeah i was still in bahrain at
this time uh
really passionate about design wanting
to achieve my dreams
so i went to university did my
background in graphic design
and did my masters in industrial design
at the university of illinois and
university of alberta in canada
and then it was time to to start
applying to these companies
and i thought that's it you know like
i'm passionate i
i thought i had the skills and i'm gonna
get in you know whatever it takes
so i applied and i think i got rejected
like i stay more than 50 times
[Laughter]
all these companies but the thing is the
dream was never shattered you know like
i always say you should dream big but if
you talk the talk you should also walk
the walk
just believing in yourself and knowing
where your flaws are your weaknesses
and finding the right mentors and
growing yourself and honestly that's
where it all
uh it all starts to come to
to reality yeah i have a question for
you there um
going back in that time you just
graduated college and you started
applying at all these places
were you self-aware to know that
my portfolio is great or it's not great
or you just
what was your mindset back then because
i know when i graduated
college i was pretty cocky and very
overly confident about my work
and i just kind of like 100 yeah i
thought i had the best portfolio in the
world
and i think like i uh i mean being at
that age
i think that it's just more about
excitement than being cocky about your
work
so you just love what you do and you
you dream about the stuff you do at
night you know so
i think it's just the excitement and the
passion that really makes you think that
that way and be that way so so if you
get rejected
50 times what did that do the problems
but uh but obviously like i tried to
to see i mean i knew where i stood and i
knew like there were many people that
were much better than me
and it was about seeing their work and
trying to be inspired by their work
and just knowing what my flaws are and
how i can improve you know i think that
having the willingness to to improve
and just knowing that you aren't there
yet and you'll never be there
i think that's a good thing to a good
mindset to have right
all right let's uh let's move on in your
presentation
so yeah uh having that dream uh
having those failures or those
rejections uh
fast forward it landed me my first
internship with the with nike in 2012.
so so for me that was the very beginning
that i could get into the industry
and this was like i think this is one of
my hugest
my biggest accomplishments that i'm
proud of
getting into nike because it was always
a dream yeah and that was that's the
energy that was the first point
so going to nike seeing these buildings
you know named after michael jordan
pete sampras uh all these great athletes
and just working with amazing people you
feel the innovation and the energy
and it just changed me as a designer 180
degrees well how did you how did you
make that big gap because all i saw was
the wallpapers from before and then
you're getting rejected and all of a
sudden you're interning at nike how did
you make that happen
so it was yeah i guess persistence like
applying over and over and over
and not giving up and like i worked
really hard on curating my portfolio
uh like going beyond of what's expected
i did actually a physical portfolio that
looked like a box
you'd open it up and each project was a
booklet
and and yeah i think like the hard work
paid off
so it's pretty good but uh but i know
like at that year i think more than
there was a few thousand people that
applied so so just being chosen among
like 12
interns that was just a big honor and
something that really helped me with my
career and to boost my career
were they able to identify for you why
they chose you
over the other thousand or so applicants
uh not really but i said to the
recruiter
i know that they had so many
applications they didn't even see all
the applications that's what i
understood so so i guess you know
there's some
there's a factor of luck but also
there's a factor of
uh presenting yourself and your work in
a nice way so
and i think that's something that
designers overcome they don't really
focus on the presentation sometimes even
if the work is really nice
but i think the way you sell the idea
it's really important do you
have photos of that work that little
presentation i do i do it's on my
i've posted it somewhere i can share it
okay yeah maybe later we can dig into it
because i i'm very curious because i
think a lot of our audience
um looks at big places like this like
nike and all the
the great aspirational brands that we
want to work with
and i see this huge gap between where
you started and then
where you arrived and this is just an
internship and the more we can unpack
that and close that imagination gap
i think the better it is for our
audience to see those possibilities for
themselves so
maybe later in the episode we can we can
dig and find that but i'll tell you this
i i went to bed back and beyond that
year and that was the only year like
they had these soap boxes which didn't
have their logo on it
it was perfect so i took that i bought
three boxes i think i had a lot of soap
that year
and just took it out made it into my
portfolio packaged it like a gift and
you know you should look at places where
it's least expected things
okay all right so that was nike which
opened a lot of doors to me through the
internship and it gave me
consultancy opportunities to work on
full basketball
football projects with them so so yeah
that was how i got into nike
and then moving on to that i got to join
again another sports brand
which i loved and played their game
since i was a kid ea sports
so i worked on fifa 15. and that was in
vancouver
burnaby in canada so so yeah that was
another good milestone for me and
another
another dream that i had so so yeah
mission accomplished there
oh my gosh okay and
and then the last stop that i'll talk
about or the milestone
is my my last job or position that i had
and that was a senior designer with
adidas in new york and i got to work on
cool basketball football running
projects
and i was a senior designer there for
three years
before i left and started my own studio
wow
that's super impressive to go from
internship at nike
uh to working at ea and then to adidas
obviously there's a clear thread there
like you said you're very into sports
and obviously you were very passionate
about that and then you worked on your
design
skills as your trade uh going forward so
to be able to hit these milestones i
think is fantastic and there are tons of
questions that
i'm sure i already have in my mind but i
also want to give the opportunity to
our audience to think about what are
some of the questions that you might
have for
for hussein here like how did he make
these transitions and
i think we'll we'll talk about that
towards the end
of the stream but i know like there's
there's a lot of questions here like how
did you do that because that's
that's so now i'll mention one thing
since i know your audience is from all
around the world
like for me the toughest i mean it's
really really tough to get into these
companies
but the toughest thing was definitely
like my situation not being from the us
and that visa situation and that can
really shatter your dreams so
like i did all my homework myself rather
than the companies because
the comp there's a lot of talent you
know they if you can't get in because of
visa they'll get somebody else and
and that's just a reality you have to
face so so there are like other ways or
ways around this visa situation that you
can
uh that you can use for it to work
and if anybody has any questions
specifically i can definitely help out
on that
cool cool so so yeah
after uh adidas i started my own studio
last year called
musawi studios and i'm focused on
bringing into my design three elements
or three ingredients which is every
design should be futuristic
modern and minimal so that's my language
or my aesthetic when i'm designing stuff
and i'll share some examples in a bit
and the whole idea behind my studio is
to blur the lines between cgi visual
effects and product design
as i said i studied graphic design and i
did industrial design
and i always had this passion for 3d art
and cgi
so i'm a believer that you can do more
than one thing and
mix and blur the lines between them and
i think that's where innovation really
happens
and a good example of that is like the
medici family in the 15th century
the way they really funded the
renaissance and push things was they
brought
people who are really good at different
uh disciplines and they brought them
together
and you had the renaissance which
happened in florence so
so that's a good example or way to put
it
and then through my studio i've been
privileged and honored to work with some
really cool clients
and these are some of the clients and
one thing i'll note here is that
people are always asking me like how do
you get these clients how do you get
these clients so
maybe a quick advice one is word of
mouth like if you do a good job it gets
more good projects and clients
and another thing is that you don't
always have to work
with the client directly like i do maybe
with half of these
but some of them are like through
agencies so that's also another way you
can walk through with other clients so
you don't have to directly knock on
their door you can knock on the door of
the people who
already work with them
[Music]
and now moving on to the projects i
don't know if there's any questions so
far
i think not specifically yet i think
people were already asking about the
visa thing but i think we could reserve
that towards the end
uh but yeah let's just keep going
through your work so i think people will
get a better idea of what you do because
we
heard some of your story i think seeing
your portfolio is going to help
connect the dots sure so some select
projects that i want to talk about
there's about six or seven projects
and my idea is to give you the key
takeaways from each project i don't want
to dive deep into each project
but just the key takeaways as a designer
so the first one is an automotive it's
called the end cycle
the end cycle was a bike that i
co-designed with my friend marine
miftier who's the architect
and our intent behind this was how can
we change
the way bicycles have looked for the
past hundred years
so we change the shape of it we change
the way that it's constructed
and the way that it's manufactured and
this got a lot of
good hype and good media and it's been
in different trade shows it's been on
different
uh museums around the world like design
museum and
gent or modern design was for moda
the museum of design atlanta uh cube
museum and so on
so it got us really good hype and good
exposure
and it also was featured in uh different
commercials
like this one for example for swisscom
and
i think the key takeaway here was that
there's two things the first thing is
that
this was meant to be a two-week project
between me and my friend just as a
concept for fun
and it became a two-year project and up
until this day like it's been six years
we're getting emails about uh people
wanting to buy the bike or
they want to take over the brand because
it's just such a
such a nice bike and the second thing is
that
like this bike reach uh prototype phase
but it never was uh
sold like mass produced but the thing is
that
through this uh conceptual project we
were able to get a lot of more
interesting projects and more
collaborations so
so if a project doesn't become reality
it's not a waste
so you can always get more out of it in
other ways
wow so for this project in particular so
you made this a
concept prototype and was there only one
or was there a few produced
we did a few and so at the moment
they're just going around different
museums around the world so there's like
bike to the future show that happens in
different
uh exhibitions and yeah it's just like
traveling around the world i don't even
know where our bikes are now
and is this uh was this self-funded
self-initiated or
did you work with any group to make this
happen
so yeah it was me and my friend and i'll
give full credit to
there's a company in italy called ncs
company
and they do lots of uh prototyping and
they did this bike for like each bike
was about 90 000 euros
oh my god we partnered up with them and
they they took care of everything so
amazing people
very professional and they do suffer
ferrari and porsche and
those kind of friends holy moly holy
moly this is amazing
so so this was a really interesting
project for me and it made me think of
how to design something differently and
this was the first project i did after
leaving nike so
i had that innovation fuel inside of me
all right so next project uh after the
end cycle we did a lot of
a lot of different collaborations me
myanmarine and this was our latest which
is called the project 411.
sorry and it's basically a tribute to
the
to the porsche 911 spider and we're
trying to take that and just give it a
fresh new look and just see what the
future of cars can look like
an interesting takeaway from this
project and cars in general is that
it's it's two projects coming together
so one is the exterior of the car
and then another thing is the interior
of the car so it's two different beasts
but then the thing is how do they live
together and
like with my experience with footwear
and textile and fabrics
i got to bring in some of that into the
interior
and then with marines experience on the
exteriors we kind of
fuse them all together so this is with
the same partner that you did the bike
with yes
marine miftio he's a architect from
albania
and we did like six or seven projects so
far together so wow
is he part of your studio or just collab
uh collaboration and he's a very good
friend he also has his own
studio so wow
so this one you were approached by by
porsha to
to create this no no this was just a
case study we did a case study
another for fun huh for fun yeah and it
got some good exposure
uh we did one also for jaguar in 2011 we
were both students
during our masters and also it got a lot
of hype and it went into different
magazines and blogs
and then jaguar wrote us it also went
under magazine jaguar magazine on the
cover
wow so yeah jaguar wrote us and we're
like that's it you know they want to buy
the bike
we're like celebrating and then they
send us like a legal notice like
guys you can't use our names
so but it was good i mean i think it got
a lot of exposure
and you know the media they twist up
they're like this is jaguar's next car
and
i see yeah i can control that one you
can't control the car rumors right
yeah that's awesome so so yeah that was
the xkx or sorry
the 4-1-1
the next project i'll dive into is
footwear
obviously i've done quite a few for tour
with the companies i worked with now can
i do this
and this was a special one for me it was
for james harden
over here sorry
[Laughter]
i guess you guys are lakers fans
congratulations on that
so yeah this was special one working
with james and personally working with
him was pretty nice through adidas and
the team there and i got to work on the
the outsole of this shoe and it was
the reason i like it is because not
necessarily the outcome of the design
but the approach
and it was a generative design and
taking data and different data points
and letting that determine what the
final outcome would look like so
so each one of these the size of it is
based on pressure
points from james feet and it allows you
to have different
kinds of traction on different parts of
the foot so
so just that approach i feel it's very
futuristic and
i feel the future is really moving
towards ai and generative design and you
can do some
really cool and unexpected stuff with it
so
so i think definitely that's uh that's a
good
takeaway from this specific project
that's awesome
yeah it's interesting and it's been like
that i think for the past at least 20 30
years
that you know i've been looking at art
and design and
seeing more and more of available data
ways to
capture uh different information
whether that be the pressure of this or
actual data that's coming in from
different entry points and then using
that to
fuel uh the design and make math
beautiful make math
visible i think that's always
interesting to me because it's it's
gorgeous when you see it in
a final design like that absolutely
absolutely
and it makes you look more of a
scientist
like you know some words people like to
use algorithms and
science and you know sure
[Laughter]
uh packaging uh this was a cool project
i did for nike for kobe bryant
uh it was called fade to black
and this was something that was his the
last shoes that were put out for kobe uh
in honor of his career and we wanted to
mimic nature in a way that we can have
these snake scales because he's a black
mamba
and then kind of see how we can
construct it in a cool way that fades
from black to white
and then convert that those color
explorations those form explorations
into something that can work on
packaging so
so this resulted into something like
this and the reason i like this is first
is for kobe so
why not why not like it and the second
reason is uh just mimicking nature
so when i did my masters in industrial
design my thesis was about
biomimicry so just getting to know why
things look the way they are
why they act the way they act in nature
it's i find it very interesting
and it goes back to the generative
design discussion that we had
so yeah so this was for kobe bryant i
think this was in 2016
whenever he retired that's beautiful i
can see a lot of people are confused
right now in the stream
and i think it's just because of the
breadth of the work that you're doing
and i know
the way that we frame this is all about
typography and we're definitely going to
show a tutorial in that at the very end
which you're going to showcase but
i think the cool thing about hussein's
work
is just the ability to explore because
we saw at the beginning of the stream
somebody who's just playing around in
photoshop making collage wallpapers
and then making this huge leap working
through the sports
uh and industrial design industry
and the things that you're doing here
really is like taking some of those
early
design concepts your design approach and
then taking that to industrial design
which involves a lot of 3d
involves a lot of modeling and
considerations like
form factor materials and all of those
things so i think a lot of people in the
in the chat are confused they're like
where are we going with this because
we're talking about typography
and why are we starting here so i don't
know if you could share anything to that
point that might help
sure sure so yeah i mean that's a very
valid point and uh
to your point uh i want to give you some
background
about my work and my thinking process
before we jump into the typography piece
and i think the number one message i
want to
deliver is that you don't have to be
specifically
you don't have to dive into one thing
you don't have to dive into typography
graphic design
product design industrial design and so
on i think just having that
diversity and your skill set and jumping
from one thing to another at least for
me
that's what keeps me inspired and runs
my creative juices in me
and there's nothing wrong with it like
like i usually see there's especially
when i was in footwear like there's the
color design that's it
all they do is color there's the
footwear designer there's the
material designer and that's cool to be
super specific and an expert in one
thing
but as a designer it's also good to to
have to have that diversity and jump
from one thing to another
and i personally find it something
that's very exciting and not limiting to
your abilities so
so yeah that that's why i guess i'm
showing uh a diverse portfolio
and it's intentional just so you guys
can see it's not specifically typography
right yeah and i think that the main
thing is we're just looking at the
finished product and
it's hard for people to imagine what
your role is
in all of this stuff just because you
know we don't see the sketches we don't
see the process but ultimately
you're doing a lot of the the 3d
industrial design
aspect of this right that's that's the
that's where you're really
putting most of your efforts into
exactly yeah so the cgi the visual
effects
like these toys i'm gonna show now
they're uh each one has a different
story behind it and
it's uh against just stuff for fun and
messing around as a designer
cool cool so this next one again it's
not typography sorry
i'm going to jump into typography don't
worry
[Laughter]
so this one is something i do on the
side for fun i like to
do toy design and it's cool because
every toy has a different message and a
different story behind it
and you can just be clever about it and
like we have fun with it like this one
for example is called don't be sheep
and it's a it's a bird but it's a sheep
so you know just play on words
just having fun with materials with
textures with lighting
and same with these examples
how fun
so yeah these are just some of the and i
actually like oh that love that
i don't know i don't see my damn roblox
yeah
that's cool this is a new one
i don't make money of this stuff and
it's not like my
the core work of my studio but it's
stuff that
it keeps you refreshed and excited and
it reminds you of why you became a
designer in the very first day you know
so just don't take yourself seriously
have fun and
yeah just play around you know i love
that
making me smile man yeah i think you're
making a lot of people smile in the chat
half of them are confused and then the
other half are just so inspired like wow
you can explore all of these things so
i'm glad you're sharing
we're gonna get the confused people
excited in a bit so
all right so just one last project
before we get into typography
uh this is called project 365. and as a
designer to challenge myself
to to do new stuff and learn new
techniques i
i put a challenge to do a new piece like
a visual piece
every single day and
so it was looking at like particle
systems looking at cloth looking at
visual language looking at how materials
uh
act in reality uh trying to bend the
laws of physics
and just having fun on a daily basis and
trying to improve my skills
and the interesting thing about this
project was that
uh i had these visuals for like a year
and i was just curating them for my
instagram and then it led me to think
about like okay how can we
do something that's based off like uh
evoking emotion through motion and that
led me to
to take these 3d stills and and create
like some
30 second 40 second motion pieces
that that can evoke different emotions
inside of you and we have that in
industrial design like sensorial design
so if you see something how it's going
to make you feel if you hear something
if you
smell something and so on so i was just
having fun with that
and i'm gonna just show two clips and
then we're gonna move on to the
typography piece
i don't know if you guys will have the
sound because it's a big part of it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know something made up it's not a
reality but it would evoke an emotion
inside
of you so this one i've called zen so
it's supposed to be
hopefully peaceful this next one is a
fun piece uh again it's gonna evoke a
different kind of emotion inside it
[Applause]
oh
yeah just having fun you know like again
this is stuff
i do on the side for my studio it's not
this isn't specifically client work but
just messing around and playing around
yeah so with these things
um do these things get you client work
i know there's you've done a lot of
exploration i'm curious does that lead
to client work or
absolutely absolutely so have the stuff
i already showed our client work
but this stuff it it always gets your
client work so
like the stuff you do on instagram
concept work and that's the thing like
uh
you're you're not just investing in
improving your skills you're also
investing in getting new business
and i've had some of the biggest brands
see like an instagram post and some
stuff that i don't like sometimes and
like should i post it should i not
well you never know so like just as an
example i posted uh
this was like 2013. i posted a soccer
ball made out of threads
i just put a nike swoosh on it just for
fun
and then a few weeks later nike contacts
me for flying it
they're like oh we did something with
flyknits and that's perfect what you did
like
cool sure so so you never know what
to what i mean just be proud of your
work and just put it out you know you
don't know what happens
i i think that's really important
because we tend to discount
exploration and doing stuff for the
sheer joy
and fun of it but i realize you know
depending on your audience and how much
you put yourself out there especially if
you've had previous clients like you
said
people who can give you that word of
mouth to the
network connection or maybe people who
are just paying attention on the side
or building something like your bike or
your porsche design
where it's it's starting to get real
traction in the niche communities that
really appreciate that stuff
then that surfaces up because the people
at those big companies at
nike at these car companies or even at
eight agencies
they're always looking for something new
they're always looking for something
fresh and it's like
that's why they love working with other
artists and studios because
they just want to be on the cutting edge
and i'm i can see it all now
as a big picture like why the ethos
of your brand your company is about you
know future tech and really pushing
the the edge on there and i can see how
you're exploring that through industrial
design and animation and now into sound
and other
other tactile things so i think it's
quite important that all of us
as designers as artists as creatives
have fun
and practice in public right because
people are watching
and you never know who's going to see it
and what that might
lead to absolutely absolutely and to
your point like
every studio in the world has mood
boards for every project so
if let's say nike puts your work on a
mood board i don't think they want to
invest time in recreating that they'll
just get you over to do it so
so it never hurts cool cool
all right so now that confused people we
got you
all right so so this was an exploration
in 2011
and this was the very beginning when
people were exploring with 3d type
i think it was around that time so so i
did this thing called type fluid
and the whole idea behind this was like
okay i want to take my
passion for graphic design typography
and i want to mix that
2d world into my passion with 3d and i
want to see what happens so
so i did this whole typographic set from
a to z
uh based on fluid simulations and i was
starting to look at
uh all right how what does it look like
if it explodes uh
if it's like i put it in a container and
then release it so the results were
pretty exciting and
i guess every letter had its own
characteristics which was
uh part of it was calculated part of it
wasn't you know it was
a surprise element and i think this is a
very good example to show like
uh how you can mix graphic design and
you can mix the world of 3d and bring
them together
wow those are great and just for those
people who are wondering what programs
did you use to generate all of these
so i use 3d max and houdini
to do my 3d i render with v-ray and
redshift
and of course always uh if it's a still
image i
i added stuff in photoshop to do the
final jobs and then
all right i totally understood all of
that maybe some people don't know what
half what those things are so
3d studio max is a very popular 3d
program
houdini is a fluid and dynamic
simulation program
redshift and v-ray those are 3d
rendering programs so
just so it's very clear those are what
those things are
cool and of course you can use any
program like people use cinema 4d they
use
maya and and that's a very good point
actually like
people i get this question a lot like
which program should i use
i don't think it's which program you use
they all do the same stuff but a switch
program are you comfortable with
and which one works better for you like
i don't enjoy this program but i might
enjoy this and it might be different for
you and that's totally fine there's no
right or wrong
that's right preach
all right so back to our tutorial uh
so yeah and this uh in this session or
this part we want to talk about
this piece which was uh i guess the main
title of this
session and it's creating this
3d typography like a neon light tube
and 3d so so the whole idea is how can
you take something that's flat and
convert it into something that's more
exciting like this
oh perfect because i know some of our
audience right now they only do 2d
design so hopefully this will bridge the
gap and show them what's possible if
they're already very skilled in 2d
exactly and the 3d part shouldn't be
scary it's like uh
it's easy techniques uh we're gonna skip
it uh
it's gonna be a bit uh fast forwarded
it's gonna get faster pace and we're
going to just talk over the techniques
and what you need to do for each point
great so like any project i started with
my inspiration uh i looked at different
references
for lighting for textures for the how
the tubes look how lights look
and so on so it's good to have a mood
board just to reference that and kind of
check on as you're working on the
project
yeah i think with mood boards is super
important to um explore details
right so you can see what other people
have done like you said the the
lighting and texturing but then even the
little details that you see like how
these uh neon lights are uh the fixtures
like where did the tubes and the the
wires go
because all the details they make all
the difference in the world i think some
people
who don't add those extra secondary and
tertiary details to their work
that's why it looks so basic but you
could tell clearly from this work and
yours
that you go the extra mile by adding
those extra layers of details the ultra
fine details that maybe no one will see
they do add up so i just wanted to point
that out 100
and it's all as you said it's all about
those uh layers of detail so
that's what makes every work special
so i partnered up with a good friend of
mine from
back home he has a studio called eje
studios and he's a calligrapher
and he does digital calligraphy and
again my idea here was to take this 2d
digital calligraphy
and convert it into something that's 3d
so this is some of his works
and he hooked me up with a nice
calligraphy piece
that was which was this one and i guess
for this tutorial the main thing
is that it should all be made out of
like
singular lines so i think like uh what's
it called calligraphy or
scripts those are the best things that
would work for neon lights
of course you can take the technique and
apply it to anything what does that say
uh this one says ramadan kareem so it's
uh
the month of ramadan it's just like
happy ramadan
ah awesome yeah yeah yeah yeah so so the
theme behind it was to lighten up it you
know it's a joyful month people get
together
and it's all about community and people
having a good time so
beautiful all right so so we'll jump
into the
first step and that's about converting
your type into paths
and what we want to do now is we want to
we want to take the
any calligraphy pieces that we have any
picture that you find online
and we want to start to take it into
illustrator
and let me play this and we want to
trace over it so so the key thing here
is to
always keep your line uh centered to the
calligraphy
so as you can see here i'm going uh
trying to keep it in the middle
and a good advice also is to
like the less points that you use the
smoother your lines are gonna look so
and i had that problem when i first
started in design i used to like a
million points and i'm like oh this
doesn't look good and why doesn't look
good so
unless there's more actually and i'm
sure matthew
you have a lot of experience as a
designer of that yeah absolutely and
the reason why is because you could see
as he's pulling the bezier points the
handles
like the more points you have the more
tension is being created between the
points so the less you have
actually the more the math can smooth
out um the curve
between the two points and i know chris
is very much about less is more when it
comes to creating beautiful
curves because that's all it is you have
two points that are just fighting each
other
and the more tension you put on there
the more messy it looks the
the less points you have the cleaner
it's going to look
for sure for sure so so yeah that's a
super easy step
just trace your uh calligraphy or your
letterings
and save it out as a path and now next
step we're gonna dive into 3d and if you
guys have any specific questions because
i know this is a bit
faster paced uh please feel free to ask
and
i'll make sure i specifically answer
every point
all right so the next part is we're
gonna
import our path that we created in
illustrator and take it into 3d
and depend i mean no matter which
program you use is going to be the same
uh i'm going to create a tube that
i'm going to create a thickness that
goes around my path
and basically what it's doing is it's
creating a circle and it's going all the
way around the
path that we created so it's making it
like look like a tube
so so based on which calligraphy you
have or which type piece you have uh
you can determine what's the cool
thickness for it and
once you're happy with that uh just go
in and start to select your points that
you created in illustrator
and again now it's just a cleaning
process so
so this is the most important process
and it's also the
i guess the basic structure of your
final design
so what i'm doing here is i'm pulling
points i'm pulling one in and i'm
pulling one out
and the whole idea behind that is that i
want to create overlapping
and i want to give it this feeling of
depth
and feeling of the lines kind of
interwined into each other
so so that's all i'm doing here and
you're removing all the overlaps because
that's not realistic right so
you're trying to make it as real as
possible if you were shaping this with a
real neon tube
obviously nothing can intersect so
you're removing the intersections
exactly 100 100 and as those and those
layering or that depth that we're giving
it that's making it look exciting
and in 3d also like you might realize
some of your points like here they kind
of look messy
and it's just about smoothing stuff out
and back to the point of less is more
removing some points that you don't need
and just cleaning the whole process up
and finally what i'm doing here is i'm
uh
like my idea is i want this uh
neon typographic piece to kind of extend
and go through a wall
so at the end i want to hang from a wall
so what i'm doing is i'm taking those
end points
and i'm making it face 90 degrees and
i'm just pulling them extruding them
so that's all i'm doing here and that's
pretty much for this step you know it's
just
it takes a bit of time but it's it's
honestly just about cleaning it up and
twisting stuff and rotating stuff and
just going into details yeah it's uh
it's very tedious and i
i never liked doing this stuff and i
always hired somebody else to do it
because
this part is so tedious to to keep it
super clean especially when you're
putting it in 3d and just for
those people who are asking this is in
3d studio max you started in adobe
illustrator
brought the pats in here and then you uh
got a
circle and you just wrapped it around
this
spline that you had to make the tube and
then you started cleaning it up
giving depth so the geometry is not
overlapping each other
and then you're extending the ends now
so it feels like it's going to plug into
a wall or a fixture
exactly exactly i'm trying intentionally
not to use any
3d terms because i know some people
don't use 3d
and some people use different programs
so i just want to keep it super generic
so if you even use 3d max i'm
intentionally not getting into
the specific name of the tool so
everybody can benefit from it
and there's plenty of options like
blender is free you could use that
for sure or even 3d mix you can get the
student edition which is
it's uh free and it has everything in it
oh wow
yeah yeah there we go so so yeah that's
that for this step
of course if there's any questions along
the way yeah i have one
uh hussein you said this is the most
important step why do you say that
because this will be the basis of how
things will look at the end you know if
things don't look clean
at this point you're go no matter how
much
uh details you add and how much the
level of depth is
it's just not gonna look good so it's
key for this
to look super clean super smooth and
then whatever you build on it is just
another layer of cleanness and another
layer of
uh smoothness this might be a dumb
question but
can you go back and refine it or like is
it once
is it set in stone once you finalize
this
no of course you can you can always do
that uh
but imagine like if you're gonna see in
the next steps when we start to build
out the details
uh if you start to clean stuff back up
like you have to go and clean everything
else that you created
so so it's good to have a good base and
a good structure
and then whatever you do is gonna you
ensure that it's gonna be clean
so gotcha but yeah that's a good
question
cool so i'll move on to the next step if
that's okay
all right so the next step is lighting
setup and materials
and again lighting is one of the most
important
topics in 3d because
if you don't have good lighting you're
not going to get good shadows good
highlights
and what i like to use is instead of
complicating stuff
and a lot of people use this as just
something called hdri maps and hdri maps
is basically
it's like an image of uh it's almost
like a panoramic image
of uh let's it can be the outdoors it
can be a studio setup
and it has all your lights set up in
that one image so what you do is you
place it in your scene and it
it gives your scene it surrounds it 360
degrees
and then it just lights up your scene
very nicely and
what i use here is from a website called
the grayscale gorilla
you can get it from there you can get it
from anywhere else and there's like
different uh hdris different colors
different
moods different tones and and so on you
know just play around with it
so those so you started with a hdri
which is it looked like you're using
studio lighting
and are you adding supplementary lights
is that what those two yellow boxes are
so so what i'm doing now is i've added a
light from the top and a light from the
bottom just to give my final piece like
an accent or a highlight
of blue and purple so like my intent was
to create
a scene that has those colors in it like
purple
blue uh pink so i think just
adding that layer on top it's also
another layer of detail that
that will make the final outcome look
much nicer
and i know this looks very foreign and
alien to a lot of people who
haven't done any 3d design before and i
think that's why
hussein is trying to just give a general
overview here but
what he's doing is after he built the
type now in 3d
he's just adding lights to the scene and
we haven't seen the the final render yet
which we're getting to right now but
he's just like you would in real life if
you're setting up an object in a studio
you're setting up lights above below to
the sides
and adding any other fill lights in
there so that you can
get some depth and shape to the geometry
which we can see here this is just a
grayscale
render right now but you can see where
the shadows are hitting
exactly and let me just show you this
so yeah you can see the purple here and
you can see the blue on the top
and it's just it's just a matter of uh
trial and error at this point so playing
around and seeing what works best for
your scene
and then the next step in this part is
uh
setting up your glass tube and
because we have the lighting set up so
even if it's 100 see-through
a glass material uh 100 reflection
uh you can see that you can see the hdri
starting to play its effect on the
on the light uh on the light glass tubes
and that said basically for this point i
mean super easy setup just to recap uh
it's an hdri map that's some fill lights
and it's setting your calligraphy piece
to to a glass material that's basically
it
that's beautiful yeah and then the
things that you can adjust in the glass
material because you could start with a
basic one
but then the things that you would
adjust are refractions right so like how
does
the light pass through it and then how
does it catch those lights and then that
will determine
where all those highlights are hitting
or how they're warped or distorted or
what happens when two pieces of glass
are on top of each other right so you
get some really cool effects in there
and
those are all the little details that i
think make it look real or make it look
hyper real and fun 100 and this next
step is exactly what you said it's uh
it's creating another layer of tubes and
playing with the refraction so
so let's get into that uh so yeah what
i'm doing now is i'm
i mean to jonah's point where his
question was about why it's important to
have a clean piece in the beginning
so as you can see now i'm duplicating
this my my tube that i created i'm happy
with
and i'm starting to create another tube
based on the tube that i just created
and for this i use the plug-in called
tie flow
and what's interesting about this is
that i can create the tube but it can
look tapered
so the ending of it can be thin but the
start of it can just have uh
be a normal circle uh as you can see
i'm doing this step so it starts wide
and it ends thin
and this will go inside of our original
tube
and the intent for this is to be less
refractive
so it's going to be a bit frosted and
when i place the light inside of this
i'm going to do another layer of light
or another tube and i'm going to place
it
inside of this one so there's gonna be a
third tube i don't know it's getting
confusing but
uh so so it's gonna it's gonna catch the
light that is being emitted i don't know
if that was clear or not
i think it's confusing for a lot of
people only because they're unfamiliar
with this process so
i know that you're creating another
piece of geometry inside but
maybe let's talk a little bit about
developing the materials
that you have in there because it looks
like you're plugging in a bunch of
different numbers and values
and is this something that's clear in
your mind is this something that you're
just playing as you go like how do you
arrive at those points where you
understand what values to plug into all
these different
uh parameters that we're looking at yeah
that's a good question uh so
i mean of course in reality things will
look in a certain way but
but the cool thing about 3d is that you
can
you can render stuff in live in real
time
and you can adjust the material so let's
say i want it to be more reflective i
want to be more refractive
and as i do that i can i can see how
things look
and i can see what looks good and what
doesn't as i'm doing here
and i guess it's just using your
judgment you know there's no right or
wrong so
so i had i created three layers of tubes
and this one like the first one is super
reflective the second one is
super uh it's frosted it's less
refractive
and the third one is just a light
material and
i didn't have any knowledge about that
how i can do it
it was more about experimenting and and
seeing what works best
so so yeah
next step of course if there's any
questions please let me know
yeah i think people are just asking
about the specs of your machine like
i'm assuming it's kind of a beastly
machine like what uh
what uh gpu do you are you running
graphics card
so yeah i use uh two nvidia graphics
cards uh
for my gpu a 2070 i
and and honestly this video is fast
forwarded so
it's not really that fast but there is
render time and
uh stuff render out and you have to wait
for some stuff like 15 or 20 minutes
sometimes
uh so that happens we just cut those
pieces up because we don't want you guys
to
be looking nobody wants to watch the
paint dry
all right but for something like this
you don't need a really good uh
like a really heavy setup so right most
things will be fine
yeah all right so the fifth step
we have seven steps by the way just so
people don't get anxious
uh the fifth step is creating the
details and the hidden gems so
to your point what you mentioned earlier
about the
layers of detail and the depth and all
the stuff that we add in the small stuff
that people don't really
pay attention to sorry
so we're starting to do that here uh so
so there's three things that i want to
add into my typography piece
the first one is adding these rings
around my
tube just like clips or something like
that
to to make it look as if it's holding it
in place
and just to give it another layer of
realism
so you can see those circles or those
rings going around the tube
and then another thing is uh i want to
create these kind of
cables or these wires that are attached
to my neon lighting
and then they are just hanging from as
if it's like hanging from a wall and
it's giving
it's giving our neon light some power so
so i'm just doing the super basic setup
because this is gonna be super small and
people aren't really gonna zoom into
these details so this took me like two
minutes to make
and just create something that looks
acceptable and
and just scatter that around on your
so you so you're drawing the profile of
this and then you're lating it so it's
just taking that
that shape that you make and then
putting it on the lathe right so it's
making that
exactly so it's just a line and then a
lit basically it's going to turn at 360
degrees
and as you can see here i'm just like
plugging it anywhere like there's no
realism to anything
does it work like that in reality i
don't know it looks cool so that's all i
care about
i'm not manufacturing this for anybody
so
so so i think the main takeaway from
this is like
composition wise see what looks best
what works best
and just use your judgment you know
there's no right or wrong like
you can't do this in a in 50 like
different ones and they can all look
good
and it's just what comes out with you
and what's what the best results start
to look like
so i know when people look at tutorials
they're like they want to position stuff
exactly in the
exact place that whoever did the
tutorial yeah it shouldn't be like that
it's all about the technique
yeah well i think it's easy for people
to follow when they see a tutorial
and they're just doing the commands and
through the action they
understand and then if they do that
three times and then build their own
version
then they kind of understand the tool
better where it's like if you're looking
at something for the first time
or if you're doing something for the
first time it's very difficult
and you want it more as much as a
coloring book as possible right it's
like here's the
spaces just let me color this in and
then i think by doing that you start to
understand oh
this is why it's shaped this way oh this
is why i put this number in
or when i change the value here this is
how it changes the refraction
and so i think that's really important
for tutorials and why people enjoy
tutorials that are very straightforward
that they can
follow and and they ask questions like
this like what values specifically
did you use and i know it's like once
you're comfortable with the tools
then you're just really playing then
you're just having fun but in the
process of learning
you want those things absolutely
absolutely and that's a that's a good
point i agree
and that's how we all learned i guess
right so
so yeah i mean uh what i'm doing here is
i'm
just putting those cables in and those
wires again like does the wire fall down
does it
go up again like you know you just use
your judgment and see what looks best
for the composition
so now you're just having fun and i
think the term isn't it called kit
bashing
where you just take a bunch of different
parts that look technical and they look
real and then you just kind of throw it
everywhere
and then it makes it look more real i
think that's called kit bashing
exactly
all right so step six of seven if we
didn't lose anyone
uh find a rendered setup uh
so for this step uh it's just going in
and honestly just looking at the details
uh
seeing do your materials look good do
they not look good
uh what i did here was i
i used the particle system uh again with
thai flow
and what i wanted to do was uh i wanted
to again scatter
a different different points on top of
my typography piece
and what's cool about this technique is
that
i can take the points that are scattered
onto my typography and onto my geometry
and i can start to connect those dust
together so you'll see in a second that
those green dots you can see what it
turns
so and the point of this is like you
have this kind of messy cable wires that
are hanging on the wall that are just
following the shape of your
neon lighting and and again you know it
doesn't have to
to be like that in real life uh
you're in the cg wall you're in the 3d
world and you're just having fun with it
and the biggest takeaway from this again
is another layer of detail you know
maybe nobody will ever pay attention to
that
but you as the artist you as the
designer you know your secret
ingredients and your recipes just like
when you go and
eat good food at a restaurant you might
think there's like three ingredients but
there's like 20 ingredients but
right you know so right
absolutely and uh just to clarify for
people here so these extra wires and
details you're making
that's just based off of the original
spline and geometry that you've already
built
so once you have something clean that
you've built you can add a whole bunch
of stuff
on top and just basically map it to the
surface
or follow the paths of the things that
you've already created so that's the fun
part
in 3ds like once you have one thing
built you can just keep adding on top of
that
very very easily and this is similar to
when we were looking at the james harden
sole right where you had the data of the
pressure points and then you're creating
that
crazy webbing for the foot right it's
kind of similar there where
you have data points already which is
the surface of this geometry that you
made and they're just mapping more stuff
on top of that
exactly exactly hundred percent five
percent cool because if you have the
geometry then you can slice stuff up you
can
put different materials you can put
different textures and so on
beautiful all right then finally we go
to photoshop
and this is for me where always the
magic happens if you screw up in 3d
photoshop is the savior
and and an important thing is like now
that we're back into
2d world uh people sometimes think that
the final render in 3d should be the
final outcome but it's not necessarily
like that so
you can take stuff out that doesn't look
that good and most of my stuff doesn't
look that good out of 3d
and i take it to photoshop i retouch it
i
add extra layers of shadows highlights
uh lighting like for example for this
one i think what really enhanced the
final image
was that i had this flare lighting uh
which i added as an overlay on top of my
image and it just gives it another layer
of uh
of coolness let's see uh so i'm gonna
add it in a second
and then also another thing that i
always like to use and i always like to
add on top of my
3d renders and it works most of the time
it's uh using noise dust particles
so just those small particles that can
live on your uh final piece it's just
gonna
make it seem much more interesting and
much more intricate so as you can see
this piece exactly
so i'm just overlaying it and you can
get loads of these on the internet even
for free
so it's nothing special
yeah i think that's the key so right now
you're really photo compositing you
could do this as
a video compositing as well but the idea
to make something look more real
is just by taking real elements and
compositing it on top so while you have
something that's inherently cold and
lifeless like the 3d
because there are so many elements that
are real like these two photos that he
just composited on top
as well as the 3d studio lighting that
you had earlier and all the details like
all those things
add up to the final result which is the
thing that's so impressive that we look
at here in the end
exactly exactly and enhancing the
lightings you know playing with the
curves uh
those kind of adjustments those are your
best friends in photoshop so
and and yeah that's a quick overview of
a very long tutorial that was
fast-forwarded and and it's all about
the key takeaways honestly like
i know some stuff can not be familiar
especially if you're not
used to 3d but it's the takeaways of
like creating the tube
creating the different uh layers like
the three tubes that we made
uh creating the details the rings around
the tube and so on so
it's just having that mindset and having
the that approach towards the design
that you do
that will make something look special in
my opinion yeah this is
this is really beautiful it's nice to
see the final result but it's also
impressive to see
the amount of work that goes into
one image and like we've been talking
about the whole stream the details make
the difference and putting that extra
layer
is what gets you these beautiful
fantastic results it's what takes
something that's
good and turns it into great right so
this is how you're gonna stand out
amongst your peers on the internet and
really pop on the radar of people who
might be looking for the stuff like the
nikes out there and the other brands
that you really want to work with
exactly exactly uh and just one more
thing talking about like nike and the
big brands uh i mean it's cool to do
stuff based off nike based of
existing brands and put it out there so
it's just uh
it's just stuff that gets people excited
and people really like the work and nike
sees that you know they can
be knocking on your door wow um so
just to help people understand how long
did this project take you to do from
start to end maybe hours or days
uh i was kind of on and off on this but
i think uh
i did this maybe in two to three days
but it was on and off
but i recreated it for this session uh
it took me a few hours honestly gotcha
cool that's not very complex all right
okay wow this is uh this is fantastic i
think i really want to open it up to the
audience
um and uh you know people are saying
mind-blown
amazing job guys brilliant wow like
everybody's very impressed and i think
some people might still be confused like
dude what did i just watch
then other people are who are on the
edge of their seat just saying wow
there's possibility so if you haven't
done 3design before
yes this can look intimidating but it's
very approachable
because there's so many great tutorials
out there
nowadays if you just learn how to look
how to make the internet your youtube
university
you'll be able to find the answer to
anything and you'll be able to make
effects just like this
or something that you're dreaming of
exactly and
i mean i get this message almost like
multiple times every day on linkedin and
instagram
like hey man like uh where can i start
how do i learn
i just say youtube.com you know like i
wish i had youtube when i was growing up
everything is there honestly everything
okay so the questions are starting to
pop in now
continue to ask your questions but i
think people want to see your crappy
work
like we've seen all the we've seen your
highlight reel we want to see the fail
the fail reel or failure
maybe maybe that initial internship
portfolio that you put together if you
do have a photo of that
i'd love for you to bring it up so that
we can see because
it's easy to get intimidated by
somebody's end result like where they
are now but they don't realize the 10 or
20 years that you put
to actually get to this point so let's
go back in time a little bit and see
like where were those
where were the steps that you took to
get to here
uh so you want to see the portfolio if
you have that um handy if you if you
think you know where that's at otherwise
i don't want to spend
it or honestly he hit it on purpose
but i have it actually that that looked
good so we want to talk about the
failures right so
[Laughter]
uh yeah i mean of course uh i mean
failures aren't stuff that you would put
on your portfolio but they're the stuff
that really build you
and i think those are the like
whenever you grow as a designer it's the
the bad stuff that you did
and you understood why it was bad and
then you improved it
and like think every designer goes
through that phase and through that
process and
it's just something to be proud of like
and i'm still learning every day
like as i said in the beginning the day
you think you made this is the day you
failed
but uh like i still have challenges when
i'm learning stuff and
i like those challenges for me it's
exciting because it means there's a
process that i'm learning something
and if i'm doing good stuff by just
opening any program that's just being
very
unrealistic and very silly about the
approach so that's not gonna happen you
know you have to fail and you have to do
stuff that sucks and you'll just grow
so so that's the best i can say for that
so
um for those of us who are wanting to
learn 3d design and do something like
this that you shared with us today
do you have any uh suggestions or places
we can go resources that we can look
into if we're just at the very beginning
level
and maybe we know how to use illustrator
but that's it
where do we go from here i mean
youtube.com
but is there any particular channels
that i think are good for people to look
into
sure like on houdini level uh there's
some pretty good stuff with the website
uh called entagma e-n-t-a-g-m-a
uh there's a guy called rohan dalvi
r-o-h-a-n
uh dalvi the alvi uh
3d max i'm not sure because i learned
that very long time ago and
like back then you know how tutorials
were you had to read stuff and you had
to do it
yes but there's some really cool stuff
on youtube i'm sure
uh same with rendering with v-ray with
redshift
and there's there's stuff from people
you like stuff you don't like you know
it's like having any kind of teacher
you like when you want like one and you
just stick to whatever you like and
that's the good thing about youtube
uh you can just fast forward you can
skip stuff
you're not stuck with one person yeah
absolutely and the other resources are
like a grayscale gorilla
um uh eye design uh
there's yeah there's also uh school of
motion our friend over at school of
motion they have a couple of classes and
free resources
that are all on getting started in
cinema 4d and later guru
i'm sorry say that again patreon there's
some pretty good
channels on there and they're pretty
cheap so
cool okay i think some people are asking
now
more industry questions so that we
understand the creative
aspect of this i think some people are
more asking about the business and the
the money behind this if you're
comfortable talking about that like
um you know what are what are rates that
people charge for
work like this or what do projects look
like i think there's just
a lot of general curiosity because this
is beautiful this is fun
now behind the the scene like what is
this is this profitable would it
whatever you're comfortable with sharing
there i think people are interested
that's a very very good question uh
so let me just say this real quick when
i left adidas
i think this was my dream job you know
like since i was a kid i was dreaming of
adidas and nike and lots of people were
like are you serious you're leaving
and just running stuff like
being outside the mindset of freelancer
and running a studio as a business
it's uh the potential is just you can't
compare it to
being a number and a company you know
like every second i invest i'm investing
in myself and my
in my name and my studio's name and so
on you know and
i'm i have a dream i have a vision i'm
trying to reach that so
so that's one benefit for sure financial
side
uh usually when you work with agencies
or with clients it's on a daily rate
most of the time i can tell you the
range depending on your skill set
it can be from 500 to 1200 dollars
a day so like if i'm working on a
project for three weeks
usually it's like five days a week
that's
how much fifteen thousand dollars if
you're doing like a thousand dollars a
day
or like some people like apple i know
they actually
i shouldn't mention any company names
they
forget about apple but those
those tech companies the big companies
with the uh let's
pay up to twelve hundred dollars a day
so that's possible
but again it comes down to the level of
the work and and what you feel
comfortable with
so so i know i started at a certain rate
and i've increased that rate as i've
been working more and more and once it
sticks and you see people are responding
to it
and you just go with it i don't know if
that answered the
question yeah yeah i think that's
helpful for a lot of people to get those
actual rates and um the difference
between
working in-house versus a freelancer
right the two gaps there's
you know depending on what your
responsibilities are
sometimes you can make more as a
freelancer
if you're constantly working right but
you the part the trade-off there is you
have to hustle
all the time and you got to make sure
that you're constantly getting booked so
if you can be booked
all year long definitely you're going to
be making more money than the in-house
person most of the time
and i'll tell you this like even with
covet this year like may really sucks
for me like
work-wise it was dead for everyone but
uh even with covet i'm still making
much more money than i used to make
in-house
and on a good year it's going to be like
let's say four times more than you make
with a
then company so i mean if you always
have the jobs and if you're always
working
so financially it's worth it uh
freedom-wise it's worth it
uh not dealing with the politics and the
egos it's worth it
like don't get me wrong working for big
brands it's it's amazing you learn a lot
you connect with amazing people you
network
uh learning curve is really high so
i'm all for that but i'm just saying on
the other side running your own business
it's also worth it at some point
that you don't get stuck 20 years
working for one brand
yeah absolutely and then the next step
from that going from freelancer to
studio owner
business owner then you have the
potential to make even more and usually
those are project rates right so
you know that could be anywhere from
like fifty thousand hundred thousand
hundreds of thousands it just really
depends and the main difference between
working in-house to freelance and then
owning a studio
is you're taking on more risk at every
step so because you're taking on more
risk at every step
you're charging more money because
you're making a bigger promise
of the success of what it is that you're
making so i
i want to just give that context for
people and it's like it gets
you become more responsible you have to
be more responsible
the further you go out right if you're
working in-house it's like a lot of
decisions are made for you
but as soon as you go out on your own or
you start running a business
then you have to make those critical
heavy decisions and sometimes they're
not fun
sometimes you have to deal with things
like kovid right and then the world
being disrupted
and then what do you do there as a
business owner and then the people that
the mouths you have to feed inside your
business
so there's there's trade-offs left and
right and you just have to be
you have to know what you're comfortable
with and be ready to do more
if you want to earn more absolutely
absolutely
cool um man
i don't know let's see okay there's some
other questions here how long have you
been working as a designer
so i started i started when i was in
school i don't know like
uh i'd say i've been
doing professionally or when i started
designing
uh how about both like when you first
started playing in photoshop
i was a kid like i don't know maybe i
was like 11 years old i was doing
websites
like games websites and then i moved on
to those wallpapers and so on
photoshop photoshop i don't know it was
which version back then
uh so yeah a very young age i was very
passionate family was super supportive
and that they always inspired me and
pushed me so that was really good
uh professionally i'd say when i was in
high school i was doing websites for
nba players like tracy mcgrady allen
iverson
yeah there were a few athletes that i
was working with doing websites and
some assets for so so that's when it
started and then i was freelancing for
like adidas when i was in college
and and yeah so let's say from 2008
professionally okay so 12 years
now fantastic oh my gosh
man so when you say yeah i was making
websites for basketball players in high
school and then freelancing for adidas
in college like i know a lot of people's
ears are perking up like what
like how did you get that because i'm
still working with the mom and pop
clients i'm still working on fiverr like
how do i
make that big jump to the clients i
aspire
to want to work with versus the ones
that i have but that's the thing and
maybe it's important to mention like
that stuff doesn't happen overnight like
i worked with so many of those small
clients as well i
uh i think that's really what pushed me
in the beginning
like the first website that i did i
remember and i was super excited about
it
it was a hundred dollars it was for a
guy who sold the
shoes true planet i still remember it so
100
it's like nothing so
i had those i had the terrible clients
that thought you would design stuff and
paint
not in photoshop and other programs i've
i've been through all that you know but
but the thing is that when you look at
somebody's career and you look at their
showreel and you look at their website
you see all the uh you see all the cool
stuff and the big names
like i'm not gonna put any of the small
names on my website but it doesn't mean
i didn't go through that process
and i think as i said uh if you have a
dream you know you
put your vision and if you talk the talk
then you walk the walk
and you have to chase that dream so if
it's adidas you go after adidas if it's
apple you go after apple
and with persistence uh i think you'll
get there
and one more thing i always tell like uh
young designers is that
at the end of the day it's it's the
people that make up the companies so
and and like maybe a big company is
lucky to have you
instead of you working so so also think
about it
the other way around if they don't get
you and you deserve to be there then
it's their loss
i love that so because i could still see
a lot of people
that it's still a big gap in a lot of
people's minds so
um ryan curell asked well how do you get
your name
out there i mean you do great work but
there's so
many other options out there there's so
many other people there's so much
competition
especially now today more than ever do
you have any tips or things that you can
share that might help somebody
stand out in this noisy world yeah i
mean
it's really noisy especially instagram
isn't helping much uh
it's good in a way because you can get
talent easily but it's also too much
competition
so i mean i've personally found it's
really good just to be active on all
platforms
and maybe a platform like linkedin i
don't see many designers training work
there but
recently i've been getting a lot of uh
good traction from linkedin
and business owners seeing my work so i
think it's
finding the places that are a bit less
crowded and just targeting those places
and as instagram you know it's like
thousands of really good designers and
that's the thing
back then when i was starting you'd have
like 10 really good designers you'd look
up to now it's everybody's good
so how do you compete it's pretty tough
but i guess finding the places where
there's
least noise that's good
yeah that's a good tip i know a lot of
people who are
highly utilizing that platform they're
publishing stuff there all the time
daily
sometimes twice a day and they are
getting attention because
that is a business network people are
there to do business
and it doesn't matter how large your
audience is it's what matters is you
have the right audience
and you have the right people looking
and you have the right connection so
maybe can you talk to that a little bit
like how did you make
the connections at places like nike and
adidas like how did you
because you say you go after them but i
think for a lot of people it seems so
intimidating like the wall is so
high and i don't i can't even look
around it to know who's on the other
side
how might someone make those connections
how does somebody find that back door
the side door in
so so for me with nike for example what
really helped me was the internship and
then when i was doing the internship i
i was really proactive in terms of
setting up meetings with
like different creative directors and
people with influence in the company
just to share my work get advice uh just
you know grab coffee with them
and that built some good connections
with me that stayed until this day
uh if you're not talking like if you're
not doing an internship somewhere
i guess it's always good to find a
mentor because people don't like to get
emails and messages that hey i have this
service
and i get those all the time and i just
ignore them because it's more of spam
but i think it's just your approach of
like hey i love your work i'd love to
see how i can grow and just have a chat
with you i think that will also make the
other person feel more special like
i don't want anything from you i just
want to learn from you and look up to
you
i think just giving them that sense of
making it more personal and about them
versus about you
i think that's the secret behind it yeah
absolutely
that's how i approach all of my uh
business development or just
relationship development in general
i think too many people are so
transactional when it comes to
messaging people online you don't know
like i probably get 10 messages a day of
people requesting for me to review their
portfolio
it's like i don't even know you but
you're asking for my most valuable
resource my time
exactly and that's that's the really
wrong approach
usually i turn those people down or you
know just delete the message because
it's like
you have developed no rapport and i
think people are discounting
the fact that you really have to spend
the time to develop relationships with
people find out
who works at these places linkedin is
the perfect place to figure it out
and then just be genuine and be curious
towards those people
so that you can develop a connection not
a transactional relationship like give
me a job
review my work how do i get an
internship because those are that's the
wrong
approach and you're never going to be
able to penetrate um
any company that way exactly i mean i
get messages
on instagram like people telling me hey
can you do me this i don't work for you
man
so the approach is really really
important
okay i want to go back to a couple
questions here and i know um
we probably have a few more minutes on
this stream uh winner pool asks
is it possible to make it from a small
country
can you be hired online if you're
outside of the us or if you
do you need to move to to get to those
big clients i mean i'm a perfect example
i come from a small
island country called bahrain it's i
think we're the second smallest country
in the world we're one of the smallest
it's a tiny tiny island so nobody even
knows who we are
uh yeah the visa is a hard thing
uh to if you want to work in the us and
some
some companies will have that as a
requirement for you to work with them
but but it's not impossible like i was
able to find my way through like there's
other options for your visa there's
something called the o-1 visa which is
if you have like achievements you can
get through
and come and work in the states that's
how i came here
uh i mean now with covet honestly this
is the best
situation that you're in it's a blessing
in disguise that
like everything is remote so i'm sure
even the positions being posted are
removed and this is your entry
so if they like you and they like your
work this is your your best chance
and a third advice is like uh like for
example adidas they
they're based in the us but they're also
based in germany okay so maybe you can
target their german office if the rules
are easier
and then you can do a visa l visa
transfer so
there's always ways around it i mean if
the company is in the us it's not the
end of the world
you can get to the us if you can't get
here you can go to another country with
the same
branch so so i guess just find your way
around it you know
i love that you gotta trade up right so
i think some people also go for the big
fish right away
but they don't play the the trade-up
game where they're working with
either the clients or the offices that
are smaller and lower in the food chain
and then working their way up people
want to just go like oh it's impossible
to get to nike but what about
all of their hundreds of other offices
around the world exactly
exactly for the agencies that work with
them exactly
those are all places that you can work
at exactly
okay so there's another question here
from uh rafael sandoval
hussein is there anything that you can
recall from your early earliest work
your early professional work uh maybe
working on websites
that you feel like it was a lesson that
you learned then that has stuck with you
or maybe developed your work ethic
going through the rest of your career
ah it's tough to go back
[Laughter]
i mean there are business lessons like
the type of clients you want to work
with you don't want to work with
i think that's good experience wise and
i'm still learning that you know
it doesn't have to be from the beginning
like there can be a client that
is doesn't pay you for example okay then
you learn that i need
the right kind of contracts maybe you
did a mistake
and we all did these mistakes like i
once uh did something for a client and i
didn't know
anything about confidentiality this
wasn't the very beginning and i posted
it online like hey
so yeah luckily i didn't get into any
trouble but uh
but you learned those things along the
way i mean but one lesson
that like stuck with me uh
i guess this one uh be humble and hungry
you know like
uh never think of yourself that you made
it and never think of yourself that you
you're you know like something really
special and always be hungry for more
and
like never never settle for where you
are
i think that's the best advice i can get
there's no ceiling
there is no spoon right all right i
think that's a good place to
to wrap up let me just do a quick recap
of the things that i heard
um why hussein is so amazing and what he
does
um because his whole career he's
explored and he's gone deep
he's gone from company to company
following his passions the things that
he's truly loved
and he puts that out there publicly he
pub
practices in public and he lets his
passion shows through
and in his work uh obviously the details
make the difference between
good and great and the more you practice
your craft
your skills and the more you're putting
that out there the more you're going to
attract
the kind of people that you might want
to work with because clients
they're always looking agencies they're
always looking for what's new and what's
next so if you're
on the cusp if you're on the top if
you're on the edge of those
conversations that are happening in
niche spaces
you might bubble up and catch their
attention and then the last couple of
things in terms of getting
the attention on of people where you
want to work
don't be transactional try and make
connection just be really genuine with
people
and don't compete in the busy
kiddie pool go out in the deep ocean and
go where no one else is playing go into
the white space so linkedin is a place
where you can definitely do that
and um obviously hussein has explored so
much
in his career from graphic design all
the way up to
industrial design and you can explore it
all in
even a short career like this and do a
lot
so don't get stuck with where you're at
don't feel like you have to settle with
what you have
but aim for higher aim for more because
there is no ceiling especially if you
know that you can do better if you know
you want more
so i think this is a great place to end
who's saying for
people who want to follow up with you
where's the best place that they can
find you
uh instagram linkedin uh email me
at my emails on my website so whatever
works and what's the handle
uh m-o-s-s-a-w-i underscore that's my
instagram
fantastic we will add that to the show
notes if they're not already there
probably update the title of this too
because i think where we went with this
discussion was different than what we
had planned and
i'm so glad we did there's so many great
comments in the
uh discussion here everybody's so happy
where we went and
really really uh happy that we get to
share this afternoon with you and a
pleasure yeah
explore all of this yeah so thank you so
much for your time everyone let's just
give a big hand to hussein
you guys also yeah thank you you did a
great job thank you so much all right
jonah take us out oh we showed you a
shout out
oh yeah shout out oh yeah before we end
we have a special shout out
actually because we are
participating in adobe max 2020 so if
you guys
don't know we've partnered with adobe
max and it's three days of luminary
speakers
celebrity appearances musical
performances
and there's global collaborative art
projects going on and
350 plus sessions an event is next week
and it's freaking free to register so
it's all online register
and max the past two years have been
amazing chris is actually going to be
one of the speakers sir
there so don't forget to go check that
out register i think it's going to be a
fun party online and going to be an
interesting experience for creative
people to to gather where
previous years it was inaccessible
because of cost and location
now anyone and everyone can attend if
you have an internet
connection so yeah cool cool
all right take us out jonah my bad all
right thank you all if you enjoyed this
session leave us a comment
like and subscribe and we will see you
all on the next one